[Musica]
vi siete mai chiesti che
rappresentazione mentale avete del
coraggio provate a chiudere gli occhi e
pensate al coraggio
qual è la prima immagine che si forma
nella vostra mente
nella mia fino a qualche tempo fa si
formava questa il leone il ruggito
maestoso del re della foresta che non
teme nessun animale
avere un coraggio da leoni diciamo
infatti spesso noi sottintendendo che
l'avere coraggio abbia a che fare con il
non avere timore di nulla che poi in
realtà pensavo che ne sappiamo noi di
quanto tremo leone mentre ruggisce il
coraggio infatti ha poco a che fare con
il non avere paura ma anzi altro non è
che la paura vinta
quello che io ad oggi ho imparato è che
il coraggio non sempre ruggisce che a
volte agli occhi bassi i muscoli tesi è
che spesso all'inizio il più delle volte
trema e adesso quando chiudo gli occhi e
penso al coraggio io non vedo di fronte
a me la potenza di un leone che ruggisce
ma vedo un mosaico di immagini in cui il
coraggio diventa quel balzo che ciascuna
di noi fa quando supera i propri terrori
in una di queste immagini insieme a me
c'è chiara che mi dice che non sarebbe
più potuta venire al lavoro perché
salire sul pullman era diventato per lei
insopportabile cuore a mille sudorazione
sensazione di morte pensieri tremendi
davvero vittoria credimi come un branco
di iene che ti accerchia e non ti lascia
via di scampo
mentre me lo diceva mi teneva la mano mi
diceva che quando era con noi al lavoro
quei pensieri tremendi diventavano un po
meno assordanti ma che tra lei e il
lavoro c'era una strada dei passi fisici
da compiere un autobus su cui salire e
che in quello spazio si infilava ancora
più prepotente quella maledetta malattia
non ricordo cosa le disse quello che
ricordo però è che passai tutto il
giorno successivo con il pensiero fisso
su di lei ricordo i miei passi affannati
che più mi avvicinavo al ristorante più
si affrettavano ricordo di aver aperto
la porta e averla vista in fondo alla
sala mentre puliva le posate sorridermi
le sono corsa incontro una corsa che mi
è scappata letteralmente dal cuore e ci
siamo abbracciate lei rideva soddisfatta
ce l'ho fatta vitti e per un attimo tra
noi le iene non c'erano più
ma c'era una speranza vera forse l'unica
possibile la speranza che nasce dal
coraggio
sono una dottoressa in psicologia
clinica e sono la direttrice di numero
zero un ristorante in cui giù del 50 per
cento del personale di lavoro è
costituito da persone che soffrono di
disturbi mentali
quando sono stata chiamata a partecipare
a questo teddy inizialmente ho faticato
mettere a fuoco il tema mobilità e
sofferenza psichica che diavolo possono
entrarci l'una con l'altra poi ho
un'idea cominciata a battermi nel cuore
avevo di fronte a me un'immagine un
momento iconico di quella che viene
definita la rivoluzione democratica in
psichiatria
il primo gesto di franco basaglia come
direttore del manicomio di gorizia
un gesto potente che si condensava nel
coraggio di dire no basaglia che entra
nel manicomio di gorizia e per la prima
volta di fronte al registro delle
contenzioni afferma mi no firmo si
rifiuta di firmare il registro delle
contenzioni quello per capirci in cui
venivano riportati i nomi degli agitati
dei matti da legare
pensate un po
il primo gesto della rivoluzione in
psichiatria coincise con una mano che
slega che restituisce i passi
dovete sapere che prima di laurearmi in
psicologia mi sono laureata in filosofia
immaginate in anni di studi quante è fin
troppo raffinate definizioni di libertà
io abbia potuto incontrare eppure ce n'è
una che negli anni ha continuato a
girarmi in testa perché nella sua cruda
essenzialità mi era entrata dentro
dritta come un pugno nello stomaco
la libertà è qualcosa che si misura in
passi aveva detto uno dei più grandi
filosofi contemporanei e durante una
conferenza gremita di gente citando non
platone schopenhauer o kierkegaard ma
gianni un carcerato a cui faceva lezioni
di filosofia
la libertà è qualcosa che si misura in
passi punto lasciando a bocca asciutta
tutti quegli studenti assatanati di
teoria sì che gremivano la sala che in
fin dei conti però se ci pensate ha
proprio ragione gianni perché quando
parliamo di libertà
parliamo anche di mobilità i passi
attraverso i quali poter incontrare il
mondo e le sue possibilità di passi
mentali attraverso i quali poter
immaginare e sperare il proprio futuro
ora voi probabilmente vi starete
domandando però che cosa c'entra fino in
fondo la libertà con la sofferenza
mentale eppure c'entra eccome perché
credetemi impazzire è uno dei modi
migliori per perderla la libertà per
paralizzare i passi per stroncare ogni
possibilità di affermazione della
propria vita lo era in modo
immediatamente visibile ai tempi dei
manicomi lo è in modo subdolamente meno
visibile oggi quando ci ostiniamo a
costruire società in cui le vite di chi
soffre di disturbi mentali sono messe
all'angolo
fa male dirselo mai così esistono ancora
delle vite che sono vite lega b li
immobilizza bili oggi non leghiamo più o
almeno non sempre perché siamo diventati
più pubblicamente e ducati abbiamo
buttato sbarre fasci chiavi serrature ma
non abbiamo liberato i passi la verità
infatti è che quando ci ostiniamo a
costruire dei mondi in cui li tagliamo
fuori dall istruzione dal lavoro e
dall'accesso agli spazi dalla mobilità è
esattamente come se li stessimo legando
pensate che la questione del lavoro per
pazienti psichiatrici
nel nostro paese ancora talmente
invisibile che non esistono neanche dei
dati
l'occupazione dei pazienti psichiatrici
evidentemente è un dato che non gli
interessa le nostre comunità
e tuttavia io credo che l'esclusione dal
lavoro non può essere considerata alla
stregua di un opzione come un'altra
perché è un atto feroce che priva chi ha
escluso di un diritto di cittadinanza
di un diritto alla vita
e sapete qual è l'unico dato certo in
tutta questa storia è che questa
necessità che abbiamo di scrollarci di
dosso il matto a che fare prima di tutto
con noi e con la nostra paura del
diverso
proprio per questo noi di numero zero
abbiamo scelto di sfidare questa paura
costruendo un luogo in cui l'incontro
fra diversità fosse rimesso al centro di
quella che è la dimensione italiana di
socialità più sacra la tavola il
ristorante quando raffaella marco
eleonora marco ed io ci siamo incontrati
sapevamo perfettamente che il nostro non
doveva essere solo un progetto di
riabilitazione per pazienti ma ancora
prima un progetto di riabilitazione per
le nostre comunità una sfida nei
confronti di un mondo che è
ossessivamente occupato ad inseguire il
progetto mistificante di una società
senza dolore
immaginate un po un ristorante in pieno
centro storico a perugia in cui il
paziente psichiatrico è colui che si
occupa di accogliere e nutrire
sapete la prima cosa che scopriamo
quando tentiamo di approssimarsi al
mondo dell'altro che soffre e che sa
soffrire non è mai solo una mente ad un
corpo ma la persona stessa e il suo
rapporto con la vita
esistenze che si fanno strettissime che
si nascondono perché esiste anche una
vergogna del dolore
pensate che una delle persone che lavora
con noi prima di entrare a far parte del
nostro progetto si era rinchiusa dentro
casa per più di un anno
sai vittoria non mi accorgevo neanche
delle stagioni che passavano
l'importante per me era non essere vista
ecco io credo che per poter alleviare
questa vergogna il male occorre
costruire dei mondi che sappiano
riconoscere valore non solo a ciò che
ascende a ciò che è integro ed
indistruttibile ma anche a ciò che cade
alla bellezza sgomenta di qualcosa che
si rompe e che lotta per rimettere
insieme i pezzi un mondo che abbia
spazio non solo per i numeri uno
ma anche per i numeri zero appunto
sapete io ricordo perfettamente durante
i colloqui per l'inserimento lavorativo
certi volti completamente trasfigurati
dalla lotta contro i demoni della
propria mente la sofferenza che
leggevamo in quegli occhi e in quelle
voci rotte era una sofferenza che ci
chiamava in causa e di fronte alla quale
noi di numero zero non abbiamo abbassato
lo sguardo
e credetemi che ad oggi quando a fine
servizio ci ritroviamo tutti insieme
intorno ad un tavolo tra le chiacchiere
le risate io guardo quei volti e
riconosco ogni giorno il senso di ciò
che facciamo
contribuire attraverso il lavoro e la
relazione a cercare di ricomporre quei
volti così come dovevano essere prima
che la società con i suoi numerosi atti
di esclusione e la malattia con i suoi
branchi di iene liszt figurassero
è chiaro che io oggi insieme a voi ho
scelto di riferirmi a chi soffre di
disturbi mentali solo nella sua realtà
di escluso perché quella delle escluse
una realtà che può chiamarci in causa
tutti e portarci a poter immaginare di
costruire una società che accoglie
invece che escludere cosa succederebbe
se le nostre comunità cominciassero a
farsi carico dei bisogni radicali anche
di queste persone e quali sono i bisogni
più radicali se non avere una casa o il
lavoro dei rapporti affettivi sentirsi
parte attiva di una comunità avere del
denaro insomma avere tutte quelle cose
che contribuiscono a definire la vita di
ciascuna di noi
succederebbe che lei ha né probabilmente
rimarrebbero lì ma accanto ad esse
comincerebbe a farsi spazio alla vita ma
per fare questo abbiamo bisogno prima di
tutto di cambiare sguardo di possedere
occhi in grado di riconoscere e
rispettare l'altro nella sua
irriducibile diversità
uno degli ultimi arrivati nella nostra
squadra si chiama alessio e quando è
venuta a fare i colloqui mi raccontava
di un'esperienza lavorativa precedente
che l'aveva molto ferito
in particolare mi raccontava di una
frase che gli ripeteva sempre una dei
suoi responsabili quando al essere in
difficoltà lui rispondeva non ripeto le
cose due volte mi piacerebbe molto che
questo numero uno potesse venire a
vedere con i suoi occhi che cameriera
eccezionale è diventato alessio quando
ho incontrato un ambiente che ha saputo
rispettare il suo funzionamento e che ha
avuto il cuore di ripetere le cose due
volte
io non dico che il processo di
inclusione sia facile non dico che basti
essere democratici per risolvere il
problema della disabilità dico però che
la sofferenza che la disabilità induce
non può rimanere chiusa nelle stanze di
chi la vive ogni giorno
dico che è fatica perché la malattia
mentale ha una sua irriducibile
scomodità
ma dico anche che è necessario misurarsi
con quella scomodità perché solo così
saremo in grado come comunità di
custodire i passi e le vite di ciascuno
è un'esperienza come quella di numero
zero serve a ricordarci proprio questo
che l'inclusione possibile
io non so voi cosa vedete quando
guardate un'immagine come questa ma
vorrei prestarvi i miei occhi perché io
vi assicuro che al di là di ogni
retorica quando io ci guardo vedo solo
una cosa un gruppo di persone a cui
voglio molto bene è una squadra di
lavoro che non cambierei per nessun
altro al mondo
quello che non dobbiamo scordare mai e
che quando non costruiamo uguali
opportunità per tutti quello che stiamo
negando è il futuro è il senso del
possibile della speranza
adesso smettete per un attimo di
ascoltarmi
e domandatevi che cosa resterebbe di voi
se non fosse più in grado di sperare se
sparisse da di fronte a voi ogni senso
del possibile e rimaneste inchiodati ad
un qui ed ora senza tempo come vi
sentireste
prima di venire qui ho chiesta chiara di
fare un esperimento le ho chiesto di
utilizzare un contapassi in un giorno
che viveva in comunità prima che nella
sua vita ci fosse anche il lavoro e di
contarne i passi le ho chiesto poi di
mettere il contapassi in un giorno in
cui veniva a lavorare chiara prima aveva
un mondo fatto di 4.060 passi aveva
4.060 passi a disposizione per far
indietreggiare almeno di un po le sue
idee né ora né a
14.860
adesso pensate a voi ad un momento della
vostra vita in cui siete stati molto
sofferenti come sarebbe stato quel
dolore liszt e là fuori non ci fosse
stato e niente ad aspettarvi niente
verso poi dirigere i vostri passi
erri de luca dice che il dolore è un
tempo di prigionia da scontare è una
distanza e va percorsa a piedi
restituiamo a chi soffre di disturbi
mentali i passi necessari ad
attraversare quella distanza che li
separa dalla vita quei passi di cui in
definitiva è fatta la vita perché come
mi diceva sempre mia madre solo la vita
in fondo sa guarire la vita grazie
[Applauso]